jacques ainsi les blacks et yvan attal
bonsoir toi
on ne présente plus on ne présente plus
on ne présente plus le grand yvan attal
c'est le film en revanche si vous
présentez l'inconnu qui accompagne yvan
attal monsieur sydney pollack
quelques films moyens
on achève bien les chevaux jeremiah
johnson les trois jours du condor yakuza
bobby deerfield tutsi par ôter rentrer
dans ta pas vu sortant et en afrique à
la firme est aujourd'hui l'interprète
avec yvan attal et puis aussi jeune
oui et puis aussi oui je suis une pelle
et nicole kidman oui mais bon non mais
c'est à dire tu es ici vraiment parce
que je suis très fier d'eux le d'abord
de le revoir et de passer une soirée de
plus avec lui mais j'ai quand même un
tout petit rôle dans ce film c'est un
film avec nicole kidman et chante pas du
tout on lui a proposé on lui a dit tu
préfères venir et nicole kidman sean
penn où ils vont atteindre
il va non ils t'adorent arrête tes
conneries tout à l'heure tu es son
acteur fétiche alors sydney bonsoir donc
dans le film l'interprète vous revenez
au thriller qui est un genre que vous
avez abordé à deux reprises en 1975 avec
les trois jours du condor et en 1993
avec la firme voilà alors j'espère le
pitch nicole kidman est interprète à
l'onu à new york
un jour elle surprend dans ses écouteurs
une conversation à peine audible où il
est question d'assassiner lors de sa
visite à l'onu à new york
le docteur ziouani qui le dictateur de
meta africains qui s'appelle le moto
beaux endroits où elle a grandi en fait
voilà
et elle prévient aussitôt sean penn qui
est agent des services secrets et lui on
vient à suspecter elle de complot en
fait c'est tout l'intriguent il la
suspecte d'être partie prenante du
complot destiné à assassiner ce
dictateur africain ce soit ni mais
heureusement il ya yvan attal qui sauve
la sphère toujours yvan attal qui est un
photographe français et qui fait des
révélations sur les atrocités du
motoball voilà ça c'est le pitch vous
aimer mon pays tu sydney le light my
[ __ ] à ce bug du tout à fait remarquer
comme description exception garder on va
regarder à quoi ça ressemble un très bon
film un très bon thriller
vous allez tous les deux regardez votre
caméra celle qui a le rouge
1 et vous allez dire en même temps sinon
ça marchera jamais vous allez dire en
même temps magnéto serge attention
maintenant avoir tout fait magnéto serge
mais tu magnéto serge tamas en lançant
attention
one two three manitoba
[Applaudissements]
j'ai entendu quelque chose aujourd'hui
je crois qu'il parlait d' assassiner le
président hu a dit
ici aux nations unies
services spéciaux un moment je prie
c'est un service officielle des états
unis d'amérique
c'est pas les états unis si c'est un
territoire international parlez-moi de
l'interprète vous croyez être en mesure
d'identifier cette voie si vous
entendiez encore
mademoiselle bronze alors pas ton avis
ait menti
vous croyez que j'invente ray un truc
pareil c'est très mature et l'attention
c'est ridicule
j'ai peur et on veut me faire protéger
par quelqu'un qui ne croient pas
à l'eau je n'avais pas l'air d'avoir
peur
avec quoi victime ou suspect que j'en
sais rien c'était qui dans le parc
ça n'a rien à voir avec vous
on va l'utiliser comme atteints
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ceci est une liste noire la dernière
chose qu'on veut voir c'est un chef
d'état étranger sans en plomber sur
notre sol cia et biarritz tout ce qu'il
te faudra 10 l'oral
il est là qu est ce que vous ne me dit
pas je ne peux pas vous le dire ça
pourrait mettre quelqu'un en danger
je lis pas je ne m'en fais pas on n'a
pas pesé sur tout ce que j'ai passé au
crible depuis le début de cette enquête
celle qui est le plus lourd passif c'est
vous
voilà la terre fait messi n'est pas là
alex jany
catherine keener et yvan attal connaître
ajouté ce soir alors c'est du bon cinéma
avec des grandes stars et c'est un vrai
carton aux états unis déjà ça marche
très très bien non c'est normal
merci j'espère c'est un vrai bon film
dans l'idéal voir là oui oui non mais
moyenne ce qu'il fait dans bien sûr
c'est un immense réalisateur on est tous
évidemment c'est un très grand acteur
filmographie du démon plus en plus
incroyable alors l'interprète sydney
c'est le premier film de l'histoire du
cinéma qui est tourné aux nations unies
à new york
parce que hitchcock quand il avait fait
la mort aux trousses s'il avait demandé
à tourner là bas et en fait ça a été
interdite par à l'époque daga marshall 1
c'était tout à fait n'ont jamais
autorisé qui que ce soit en fait venir
filmer dans les bâtiments des nations
unies mais je veux dire que moi j'ai
fait preuve de persévérance je n'ai
cessé de poser la question de demander
redemander redemande et finalement j'ai
fini par voir kofi annan en personne
j'ai passé une bonne demi heure avec lui
et je crois que finalement j'ai
simplement eu de la chance je crois que
c'était le bon moment
je crois que c'est hitchcock vivait
aujourd'hui il y serait aussi dans le
bâtiment des nations unies alors nicole
kidman et sean penn c'est un couple
formidable passé comme grace kelly et
kyle grande que c'est vraiment un coup
de main geneviève est un peu un peu
alors nicole kidman c'est un très bon
choix parce que vous l'avez prise pour
faire le rôle d'une africaine blanche et
comme elle est australienne ça donne ce
côté un petit peu exotique elles
auraient pu être sud-africaine nicole
kidman en fait oui c'est ça ne semblait
pas être quelque chose qui aurait pu
marcher d'avoir une actrice américaine
l'enjeu c'est la première personne à
laquelle je pense je la trouvais très
crédible en tant que jeune américaine
mais qui se sent parfaitement à l'aise
en anglais qui le parlent couramment qui
a un petit côté que ce petit corps
t'aurais pas tout à fait sûre qu'est ce
qu'elle est en train fixe de cinq ans et
pour éveiller les soupçons
elle avait suscité la sympathie donc
c'est à elle que j'ai pensé en premier
alors nicole kidman est originaire du
mot turbo et elle parle le coup c'est
une langue que vous avez inventé le cul
[Rires]
savais pas ce que ça voulait nous avons
un continent
[Rires]
c'est très bien aussi de dire ça mais en
fait on est allé dans un institut des
langues étrangères à londres et on a
créé de toutes pièces une langue en fait
c'est une combinaison document qui
existe vraiment le swahili donc qu'on
parle en afrique orientale et puis le
chemin qu'on parle en afrique australe
et donc on a fait un espèce de mix des
deux pour créer sa langue
ce n'est pas très difficile parce que de
toute façon personne ne pouvait savoir
si vous aviez fait une erreur puisque ça
n'existe pas et brèves l'appeler le cul
qu est ce qu on appelait ça car shoe
excusez moi j'en sais rien je n'ai pas
pensé à ce nom là je ne savais pas
jusqu'à ce soir ce que ça voulait dire
en français alors face à nicole kidman
vous avez choisi un acteur de poids donc
yvan attal
oui vous êtes content qu'il ait accepté
de travailler avec vous il était mon
premier choix
j'étais pas sûr que ça allait marcher
parce qu'il avait énormément de choses à
faire il réalisait et travailler sur un
film puisqu'il s'agit de l'est qui
viennent jouer pour moi c'était au
mixage de mon film vous savez on avait
des problèmes de calendrier en plus il a
fallu que je change les dates pour être
sûr qu'il vente puisse venir avec nous
tolac déplaçant planning chante pour car
quand tu es allé le voir il a eu
l'élégance de dire que ça lui faisait
plaisir de travailler avec toi non c'est
ce qui fait les grands metteurs en scène
enfin j'ai eu l'impression que enfin il
a été très chaleureux tout de suite
c'est le premier rôle que j'ai eu aussi
facilement
a priori je suis arrivé dans son bureau
je vais rencontrer pour la première fois
je pensais que j'allais devoir lire ou
faire quelque chose et gare au moment je
vais lima il m'a dit au revoir jeudi
mais mais quoi qu'il se passe j'ai pas
lire ou quand elle m'a fait non c'est
bon tu le fais si tu as envie de le
faire c'est toi et j'étais vraiment très
surpris et évidemment je veux le dire
encore très honoré de travailler qu'un
metteur en scène qui m'a vraiment en
tout cas moi donné envie de faire du
cinéma
voilà bien sûr devenu un peu de nouveaux
genres et nomma yapi rien à faire non tu
t'en sors bien est ce que tu as dit à
nicole kidman que tu faisais la voix
française de son ex non mais je les dis
à sydney quand j'ai rencontré parce
qu'en fait ayant doublé tom cruise dans
les white sox
j'avais énormément de scènes avec sydney
pollack donc c'était étrange de le voir
et de le rencontrer j'avais l'impression
que j'avais déjà fait un film exclusif
loi
tu as parlé qu avec l un peu coût
inconnu
c'est seulement internet extraordinaire
spielberg la peine sur son portable
sydney pollack lui propose des rôles
c'est magique non c'est plutôt agréable
de travailler avec des metteurs en scène
wen qui font rêver et puis et quand j'ai
vu l'interprète j'étais vraiment c'est
marrant ça fait je ne sais pas une
quinzaine d'années que je fais du cinéma
et qu'on est quand j'ai vu les premiers
plans de ce film j'ai eu un sourire
comme si un rêve d'enfant se
concrétisait quoi voilà parce que c'est
vraiment le cinéma c'est le cinéma
cinémas moi-même quoi c'était le cinéma
voilà c'est du cinéma et c'est drôlement
bien
alors maintenant que tu es devenu une
star à hollywood on va te faire une
interview suicide à hollywood qu'est-ce
que vous n'avez pas errer sur le
tournage de l'interprète avec sydney
pollack une chose assez désagréable
c'est qu'ils y réécrit sans arrêt sans
arrêt sans arrêt le scénario j'étais une
semaine à new york avant de tourner la
scène parce que j'ai eu une scène un
petit républicaine duffy et pendant une
semaine j'ai travaillé avec un coach
pour essayer d'être déjà de me faire
comprendre en anglais et au dernier
moment la veille j'ai une petite
enveloppe dans ma chambre je rentrais
dans ma chambre j'ai ouvert les
enveloppes et c'était un nouveau texte
est vrai qu on réécrit donc je suis
arrivé un peu stressé un peu stressé il
se saisit c'est vrai qu'il lirait
écrivait tout le temps ce script
qu'est-ce qui est ratée dans ce film là
probo un peu ce enchaîné nicole kidman
en bien qu'est-ce qui sait pas faire
s'il n'est pas là qu'au cinéma
les claquettes
qu'est ce que vous savez pas faire au
cinéma des merdes et peep show dans une
émission comme celle ci où il coachait
j'en parle une autre je vous assure que
c'est affreusement compliquée want to
speak q qu'est ce que sean penn ne sait
pas faire il sait pas se faire mâcon
c'est ça moi voilà six mois que vérifie
quand même niveau qu est-ce qui t'énerve
chez nicole kidman par la tâche non j'ai
saisi le premier plan qu'on a tourné
justement sur ce banc j'étais je suis
sur le banc je sens il attendre et elle
arrive ça fait des années qu'on sait pas
vu on est censé tomber dans les bras
l'un de l'autre
c'était le premier plan que j'avais à
tourner j'ai un fils antilles mais pas
ridicule un ridicule c'est que vraiment
l été et heureusement il a eu la
délicatesse de clubs de faire un caillou
créé très large ce qui fait que personne
ne remarque vraiment ce truc là mais
c'est énorme quand même qu'est-ce qui
était insupportable sur un tournage aux
états unis
à vrai dire comparé au tournoi je
pensais c'est les heures c'est à dire
que tu as l'impression que tu travaille
24 heures sur 24
tudor patassé s'est tu tournes je sais
pas combien d'heures par jour
c'est vrai que c'est très c'est déjà
fatiguant on se rend compte sur un film
français combien c'est fatigant mais sur
un film américain d'assumer un rôle et
d'un d'un tournage comme ça aussi long
il ya des heures c'est incomparable avec
nos heures de travail et nous avec qui
tu aimerais pas jouer à hollywood avec
alain chabat ce qu'a fait chier fait
chier way et toi un 7 d'or gens viennent
pas là tu fréquentes d'avoir un dossier
je rêve la nuit
[Musique]
bon ok vous pouvez emporter un élément
du décor avec vous arrête avec geneviève
tu veux remporter quoi joue pas je veux
chapeau jusqu'à ma mort ben écoute
attend un peu près sur le coup toi
[Applaudissements]
vous devez porter un grand chapeau
à
le mec se donne du mal nec se donne du
mal
il fait un film avec nicole kidman sean
penn des sourires maintenance qui sera
lancée que vous échangez vos chapeaux
non
oh non
geneviève asie mais le sais pas c'est
quoi c'est pour mes gosses ah oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça sort
ces risques
avant je me laissais qui n'est pas ce
qu'ils vont se coucher petit devant elle
est d'avis lutter
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu